four years ago Adam Hussein fled his
war-torn homeland Chad and was granted
refugee status in Germany he now works
at a bakery in the town of burg Fadel in
lower saxony after a 10-week training
period his employer offered him a
contract he's now in the second year of
his apprenticeship for launch in Shive
had he not long I used to work in a
bakery in Chad was Ethan that's why I
wanted to do the training here
unfortunately it worked out but Maha was
a hominid though who is allowed to work
in Germany as a refugee the labour
office can process job requests for
asylum seekers who resided legally in
Germany for at least three months but
only for jobs that can't be filled by a
German or other EU citizen and even then
the country's immigration office has to
approve the employment contract so how
qualified are those seeking asylum
statistics from 2013 showed that 13% of
all working aged applicants have a
university degree a further 24 percent
of only completed secondary school 58
percent of the applicants have no
training at all qualifications therefore
varied widely like many other asylum
seekers Adam Hussein has had trouble
learning German the Ministry of Social
Affairs says that in the coming year the
language lessons training costs and
living incomes Germany pays for asylum
seekers could cost up to 3.3 billion
euros at the bakery in Berg beetle
Hussein in his boss get along well
despite the language barrier as an
excellent he's a great person and a good
worker I knew that after the first
10-week training period was destined for
the asylum seeker one thing is more
important than any other that his
training contract grants him the right
to stay in Germany without having to
fear deportation and one day he hopes to
own his own bakery his boss says that
when he retires Adam will get his chance